ياسين ياسين ياسين ولا ياسين
حاجه من ربنا
مع انتهاء منافسه دراما الرمضانيه تبدا
المنافسه على الشاشه كبيره السينما مجموعه
من النجوم يتنافسون في موسم عيد الفطر
باقى متنوعه من الافلام طرحت في دور العرض
ما بين الاكشن والرعب والفانتازيا
والكوميدي الذي يعتبر الحصان الرابع في
مواسم الاعياد
من بين هذه الافلام فيلم ساعه اجابه الذي
يدور في اطار من الفانتازيا حول طفل يتمنى
تغيير ابويه وتتحقق الامنيه
اهم حاجه
[موسيقى]
الفيلم بيحكي عن قصه طفل عنده مشاكل مع
اهله زي اطفال كتير قوي اهلهم زي الفل بس
هم عندهم مشاكل معاهم لغايه ما في يوم من
الايام بيتمنى من ربنا ان هو يغير له اهله
فربنا بيدي له مجموعه اهالي مختلفه وبعد
كده بيعرف ان الله حق يعني فيلم موجه
للاسره كلها وخاصه الاطفال وفكره
الفانتازيا اللي هي الحدوته فيها نوع من
الفانتازيا
النزهه المفضله للمصريين في مواسم الاعياد
من بين الافلام المطروحه ستستمر الافلام
التي تحقق ايرادات مرتفعه الى موسم الصيف
[موسيقى]